[Musique]
il est ordonné statut est décrété que
walter macmillan sera exécuté par
électrocution
c'est mon père monsieur asseyez-vous
jeune homme donne assis toi maintenant
il a rien fait de mal tu monsieur le
président un instant je ne le répèterai
pas asseyez vous passez vous tuer mon
père sans raison que tu es ma famille
monsieur
il est clair que ce procès est bâti sur
les mensonges quand on met un noir dans
le couloir de la mort un an avant son
procès dans toute preuve attestant de
son innocence était tout fait et que
tous ceux qui essayent de dire la vérité
sont menacés
ce n'est pas la justice
ce n'est pas bien
j'étais pas les poches jamais de la vie
c'était comme regarder une rivière plein
de gens qui se noient sans savoir quoi
faire pour les sauver
vous savez pas quoi vous exposez ils
n'ont pas besoin de preuves combien
parmi vous est fait avec walter ce matin
là
[Applaudissements]
keita l'appareil le titre qu'a posé bon
ajouté barak tout le monde sort de la
maison
à
votre vie compte toujours et je ferai
tout mon possible pour que personne ne
vous la prenne